oui le mouvement de liberté que j'ai
créée
voilà je me suis lancé ce délire un jour
j'étais dans une boîte de nuit
libertines puis avec la patronne de ce
bar là précisément elle me dit mais si
tu te présenter parce que tu es écrivain
principalement libertin j'écris des
livres érotiques et libertin la fiche de
campagne et regarder la petite fenêtre
en haut à gauche ça c'est l'elysée
demain
ah oui ça va changer
ça c'est mon projet
tient à 2 ce soir que mais la cravate et
le cosmique sur ministrable
mais jamais le costume et la cravate ce
soir ils savaient qu'ils avaient une
canne ni la présidentielle a dû se dire
mais j'ai parlé avec lui toute leur
place j'ai rencontré salaires on disait
que le handicap était pas présent dans
la campagne mais le sexe et l'amour non
plus mes cd de ce genre des domaines qui
ne sont absolument pas abordée vous
exactement et c'est pour ça que dans le
mon programme il ya des choses qui sont
très sérieuses il ya d'autres choses qui
sont beaucoup plus légère alors c'est ça
le sérieux sur la liste a tous mal à
l'aise je sais je sais ben on juger été
pas mal complimenter notamment par j'ai
eu du bol d'avoir à toute une page dans
charlie hebdo il ya quelques mois de ça
la bamboche c'est maintenant ça a été
titré comme ça ça m'a fait super plaisir
au cou a fait un dessin d'enfer qu'elle
ne peut pas montrer ce soir à l'antenne
dominique jsk nous a rendu hommage aussi
j'ai vu à ben voilà donc j'étais très
satisfait et crédit quitté suivait de
près et oui mais ce que je veux dire
d'andorre voilà moi je défends cette
philosophie libertines mais pas que
c'est à dire que la liberté de mouvement
des libertins il faut ajouter et de
toutes les sexualités je milite beaucoup
aussi pour la nana de la cause
homosexuelle ont parlé d'assistance
sexuelle je trouve que c'est
complètement hallucinant que ça n'existe
pas tout comme des projets qui sont plus
sérieux ça fait des années que des
candidats les candidats successifs dans
l'est mais voilà on l'a me voilà l'image
mais je remercie coco d'achat voyons
peut-on entrer ici voilà
on parle d'assistance sexuelle mais on
parle aussi des animaux on parle de il
ya plein de plein de sujets qui sont
très importants pour la société comme
par exemple le remboursement s'est même
pas le remboursement les des produits
d'hygiène les capotes etc vous savez je
vais vous dire quelque chose c'est sûr
le serviettes périodiques tampon les
préservatifs réservé de remboursement à
100% mais bien évidemment mais c'est
assez sérieux dans mais c'est sérieux il
ya des choses beaucoup plus légères
comme organisé
le week-end du naturisme mais par
exemple voyez je parle de jour férié
dans mon cas et je veux vraiment asseoir
le fait qu' il ya des choses très
sérieuses a peut être pris à la légère
bien sûr la sexualité aussi peut être
pris à la légère de fait le libertinage
c'est de rendre hommage par exemple un
jour férié à la jean diot et bruno
lenoir ils ont les derniers homosexuels
qui en 1750 à paris ont été condamnés à
mort voilà je trouve que ça serait
important de créer pourquoi pas associée
on associe plein de jour férié des
années à des faits et des événements il
est vrai dramatique et je trouve que ce
n'est pas dramatique de ce ne serait pas
dramatique de le rendre hommage comme
rendre hommage aussi à tous les tous les
homosexuels qui ont été déportés et qui
porte l etoile rose je trouve que ce
serait la moindre des choses organiser
des conférences organisées des
travailler avec des associations et
salle hubert est un petit peu l'esprit
et ça peut être ça ouvrirait des portes
aussi à toutes les sexualités qu'elle
soit libertines au mot gay trans
également dans le ce polyamour je trouve
qu'il ya des choses intéressantes à
creuser comme par exemple moi ya des
choses qui me touchent il ya plein de
gens ils ont des animaux je suis très
sûr et que avec ma compagne laeticia les
traits milite beaucoup et moi je c'est
elle qui m'a pris en fait il m'a fait
découvrir cette cause là bien bas je
trouve que ils devraient les mutuelles
c'est quelque chose beaucoup de gens ne
peuvent pas se payer c'est hors de prix
c'est plus cher c'est deux fois et demi
le prix d'une mutuelle pour un être
humain il ya un truc qui tourne pas rond
dans notre société mais dans une société
internet aux préoccupations c'est très
vaste ah oui c'est ça c'est ça et je
trouve que avoir des bons par exemple
tout simplement en fonction des revenus
pour pouvoir acheter chez un veto des
bonnes croquettes et pas des trucs de
merde de du luart discount qui me
pourrir le dans la question est sérieuse
parce que ce soir n'y a pas de tabou
vous pourriez défendre la zoophilie et
non pas mais non mais là on est mort
alors là je pose la question je
conditionne pour entrer en jeu la
question je vais je vais être très franc
avec vous au fil sur terre oui mais je
vais être très franc avec vous et je
vais très cash vous me décevez je vous
pose nécessairement non vous me décevez
parce que je trouve que ce n'est pas de
votre niveau que de poser ce genre de
questions vous même qui avez une
question bête non il n'y a pas de
question bête mais je pense qu'avant
celle du sexe tout d'un coup on embrasse
la cause animale je me pose
mécaniquement la question on pourrait
très bien avoir eu quelqu'un ce soir
qu'ils soient venus témoigner parce
qu'il était amoureux de son cochon d'art
moi je ne pense si c'est si vrai que ça
je pense que ce genre d'interrogations
c la fatigue si je pense que ce genre
d'interrogations
ne devrait même pas avoir lieu parce que
bon c'est bien vous savez très bien
faites vous même qu'il n'y a aucun lien
le libertinage avec la zoophilie où vous
le savez bien mais vous posez quand même
la question ne sais pas je pose des
questions vous savez la seule chose et
ça les téléspectateurs doivent le savoir
surtout s'ils ont des enfants il n'y a
jamais de questions stupides réglé je
sais bien qu'il ya des réponses qu'il
veut je sais bien comme par exemple
peut-être la vôtre en ce moment mais la
question n'était pas stupide il était
curieuse ça se passait bien jusqu'à
présent non mais ça se passe rien on
ménage et zoophilie c'est comme tu es
venu sur la question animale ici dit est
ce que dans son esprit mais qui n'a rien
à voir avec la liberté leur come back
heures de queue est ce que cette
question je
m'élance est question allez je te
considérais qu'il voulait c'est vrai que
là on atteint voilà la zoophilie c'est
quelque chose c'est que ces gars c voilà
ça rien à voir sur mais pour revenir et
je comprends je comprends bien grave
vous avez répondu avec la toile a
répondu voilà c'est seulement faux mais
le jeu ne fait pas que ça j'ai écrit des
bouquins j'écris j'ai écrit d'ailleurs
une bonne une très belle histoire dont
on à bouquin que j'ai écrit il ya des
extraits sur sur mon site internet sur
google on trouve plein de trucs sur des
sujets qui sont aussi importants qui me
tient à coeur comme la journée du devoir
jean duo bruno lenoir je trouve que ça
c'est intéressant c'est oui alors
pourquoi vous mélanger les choses a qui
sont très recevable avec des choses un
peu folklorique parce que je lis dans
votre programme d'organisation du
week-end du naturisme partout en france
tous les ans mais bien sûr et pourquoi
pas en allemagne il ya une quarantaine
de pays dans le monde et parfois dans
les pays qui sont pas forcément ultra
démocrate je peux vous dire que y'a des
parcs comme en allemagne qui sont
réservées et quasiment six mois dans
l'année si ce n'est plus au naturisme
donc effectivement je disais il y avait
des choses légères y avait des choses
beaucoup plus sérieuses crémel jeux
olympiques naturiste ah oui ça c'est ça
c'est un petit délire
j'espère c'est les jeux d'été pas les
jeux d'hiver
un peu problème le plus rigolo ce serait
l'hiver
mais en france et pourquoi pas et jeudi
après plus tôt après vous non mais vous
revendiquez ce côté un peu d'écho nord
par phinney s'est bien évidemment c'est
la peur que sa mine un peu jeune mais
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose mais
il se prend pas au sérieux je vais non
je me prends pas au sérieux mais en même
temps j'aime a essayé d'avoir des idées
et si ça pouvait faire si ça pouvait
tilter à quelqu'un un élu qui nous
regardent et des oui c'est vrai qu'il
serait ton qu'on compte que ce soit
gratos les préservatifs oui j'ai
vraiment à part ça donc oui il ya des
choses sérieuses il ya des choses
beaucoup plus légère mais je n'hésiterai
pas même sur la déportation des
homosexuels vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est une vraie cause qui pourraient
être prises au sérieux c'est vrai voilà
donc il ya des devoirs de mémoire qui
toute la journée
ont pignon sur rue c'est vrai que c'est
celui là il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
nous regardent qui ne savent pas que les
tziganes les homosexuels ont été
déportés pendant la guerre et il ya eu
des victimes nombreuses dents parmi les
homosexuels au prétexte qu'ils aimaient
des gens aimer les hommes ils ont été
déportés et assassinés exact donc ça
c'est une vraie cause nationale
intelligente bon les jeux olympiques
naturiste ça fait un peu bande des jeux
mais je mets une pâle effectivement
effectivement il ya une part il ya une
part d'humour mais moi ce que je veux
vraiment je veux insister là dessus
c'est que ce se savait le mot libertin
bien vient de la romantique ça veut dire
esclaves qui vient qui a été ou qui
vient d'être affranchi etc on
n'appartient à personne il n'y a pas de
plus de dogmes établis sur bien pensante
quelconque ça n'empêche pas notre
sérieux et le libertin aussi peu moi
j'ai fait des soirées libertines il ne
s'est rien passé rien de rien mais on
s'est marré on a fait la fête on a mangé
du bon fromage on a mangé de les
conneries des tapas ça c'est la vie et
enzo coup de liberté j'ai fait des
soirées non la partie puis s'est passé
des choses alors là l'assistance garde à
vue
[Applaudissements]